what other factors contributed to the
opioid crisis then yeah boredom will get
into it living in a [__] town the [__]
of the town the bigger the Opium problem
and I'm I'm I know I'm joking at this
but that is boredom so like you know if
you can make
put a couple more Six Flags around the
country you probably
you could probably
as president
Six Flags and everything look you and me
have driven through some towns I like
where you like I get it yeah yeah I get
it and to what you were speaking about
before in Europe for whatever reason
there's always a theme park in the
middle of everything yeah
especially like in the Norwegian
countries like why is there a roller
coaster in the middle of this town so
they're always there stop the Opium yeah